our next speaker is Andrew Johnson
oh I couldn't resist beginning
introduction to Andrew Johnson by
drawing his own biographical instruction
on his website which reads andrew
johnson was born in court in the New
York to a jazz guitarist Civil War
historian father and science major
mother who together one many bowling
tournaments he made his first life-size
bow bronze sculpture of Baron Manfred
von Richtofen at the age of 13
literature marzipan figurines and Fats
Waller at 11 and his first film cycle in
the Battle of Gettysburg at nine
unfortunately nothing Andrew never did
over the course of its suing his ensuing
career we brought the level that early
work but nonetheless I think that we
should recognize they acknowledged that
at least some has worked since then has
been amply demonstrated displayed across
the world the combination of exhibit
performances and showings which is
Andrew tells us seek to both address the
exigencies of the daily realities of
daily realities and to undress the
refined aesthetics of art so just
do the Haitian grassroots movement in
level us homelessness in Cincinnati's
over the Ryan neighborhood in a dressing
room unabated selling the planned minds
in spring let them keep their children
tether crises in the Middle East
impressed when Wordsworth police pulled
the annunciation to victory pluck and
gazelles etc etc in 2001 Andrew Johnson
co-founded PDD head with Millie chin and
pawpaw news head is a socially engaged
collective that is offered bicycle
lecture tours for international site
specific projects ranging from Buffalo
Hamilton Buffalo to Hamilton the Belfast
to chongqing in rio de janeiro and since
2001 and probably most relevant for us
today in a variety of settings and it is
homework painters taken on issues of war
violence and the mechanisms and
projections of terror and quotes and
terror without quotes and while always
drawing attention to is refined
aesthetics so Andrews presentation today
is entitled in other words let me
rephrase that
okay so you clap too soon I already got
some okay thank you very much Paul and
Adam it's really nice to be here and
thanks to see is Paul I have a dig for
you later in the presentation so but if
anyone would like to leave this would be
a good time are you cold because I feel
a draft coming on a really really rough
draft here okay so all right when I
found this guy one night crawling
endlessly through a pattern sand
blindfolded by his overgrown plume while
engraving with his richard the lionheart
replica sword of the Third Crusade and
simultaneously erasing his misspelled
Proclamation victory I thought how
amazingly like me he was he like all
true red-blooded black gold seeking
patriotic Americans created a role of a
superhero who combats supervillains that
are invisible and so on the present he
was a knight errant and erring
unperturbed and perpetually pursuing
with moral certitude the righteous path
in an era of evil and greatness taking
his stand on his knees forging new
frontiers claiming that which is already
prescribed staging a rehearsal for a
disaster he already has caused if this
description sounds all too familiar it
should three days after the first
attacks on Afghanistan resident
neoconservative american enterprise
institute think tank scholar michael
leaden wrote surprisingly that we have
recovered the roots of our national
character which are an unshakable
confidence in the righteousness of our
mission deep religious conviction
and the unique ability to come together
to prevail against frightening obstacles
next time we must dismiss those who tell
us that all people are the same all
cultures are of equal worth all values
are relative and all judgments are to be
avoided my role today is that of
introducing several tactics with
contemporary artists which the tactics
they take in redressing the war on
terror narrative that are taking place
within and outside the art world proper
that is to say that these examples are
of works that function within the museum
the blue-chip commercial gallery the
state supported international biennials
the private and publicly funded new and
alternative museum and exhibition spaces
the interactive web live feed gaming
community as well as the non
institutionally sanctioned artists
organizers activists and street actions
I've brought them together in this
context where I believe that they share
many aspects namely clearly articulated
target public's to engage well
considered modes of execution as well as
critical concrete aspirations they are
affecting and effective caustic and
comic empowering and entertaining and
you topic as well as realist they are
all generous in their outreach to wide
range of audiences and participants are
startling in their evocative and
surprising use of imagery the urgency of
their subjects command the consideration
for the efficacy of their ability to
communicate they are nothing if not
topical frequently taking place in real
time or even prophetic as well as in
debe indelibly haunting I have
interspersed references to news events
of the last few months or even days to
indicate the continuing relevance in
uncanny applicability to our actions
this hour to show yet again that the
past isn't even past
I wish to introduce or represent these
works today is demonstrative of
divergent perspectives not merely in the
sense of demographic constituency of
their subjects and viewers but literally
from the vantage of the work the works
are created from views that are intimate
I Supreme morphic and remote monocular
stereoscopic and cross-eyed blind and
haptic superimposed and rosy color
virtual and automated and typically hold
many of these positions simultaneously
colon Paul on February fifth 2003
addressed the UN Security Council he was
talking in providing evidence about the
mobile production facilities for
biological agents as the centerpiece for
evidence in favor of the invasion which
took place on March twentieth 2003
okay well I thought you were looking at
that just a moment ago okay so Colin
Powell had to cover up the mock tapestry
of Guernica a dwarf version of the
painting itself that hangs in the UN he
covered it over with blue curtains
because he didn't want the image a
protest against unilateral bombing that
took place by the Franco regime funded
by the Nazis in 1937 to be equated with
what we were about to do subsequently
the Guernica uncovering and this is the
part that I am throwing in here for Paul
because this exhibition or this piece by
the artwork the artworks collective in
February 2003 was displayed in Hollywood
and it is a uncovering of the UN
buildings covering over of Guernica so I
got three ons in there so that's as good
as I can get for you Paul okay yeah just
watch what you take photographs of
social activists artist writer and
provocateur Trevor Paglen has been
exploring the secret activities of the
US military and intelligence agencies
the black world for the last eight years
publishing speaking and as an artist he
is interested in the idea of photography
is truth-telling but his pitchers often
stopped short of traditional ideas of
documentation in the series limit tell a
photography for example he employs
high-end optical systems to photograph
top-secret governmental sites in other
works Paglen transforms documents such
as passports flight data and aliases of
CIA operatives into art objects the
questions he raises do not negate
historical or political force of these
images but through their formal
qualities
decelerate our ability to act upon what
we see by creating a sense of doubt and
uncertainty in the face of visual
information causing us to ponder in the
temporal space created by the
photographs complex and uncertain
relation to knowledge and truth what
activism would look like if it were
founded on ambiguity incomplete
understanding doubt obscurity rather
than slogans unity loyalty and coherence
if it began from a recognition of the
limits of the visible and our
concomitant inability to render the
world transparent this photograph here
is of a black site taken at 42 miles
much of the current position to the war
on and of terror in general and to the
Bush administration sanctioning of
torture in particular has relied on a
political strategy of exposure which
human rights organizers refer to as
mobilizing shame photographs play a
central role in the shaming process
rather than understanding pag lens
images within the exposure of shame
economy we might more usefully
understand the limit of telephoto
graffiti Ruiz is exploiting qualities
inherent to photography to create
discursive spaces in which to reflect on
present alternatives to existing modes
of digital activism so that was an
expended and extended quote by Karen
Beckman from the art journal in 2007
this project involves our own rich Pell
tagging up with Trevor Paglen and rich's
institute for applied autonomy the
terminal error is a project that
explores the thoroughly modern
extraordinary rendition program
enterprise that is largely carried out
using leased equipment and private
contractors these private charter planes
often use civilian airports for
refueling making their movements subject
to public record invisible to anyone who
knows which tail numbers to look for
with only knowledge of what these planes
have been used for in the past human
rights activists are left to their own
move
is a vast black box and can only
speculate whether any specific plane is
currently carrying human cargo and route
to being tortured in a so-called CIA
dark prison represented on to wall
displays is a speculative visualization
of the known movements of some 30 of
these planes the map indicates the
planes movements during the last six
years periodically new information on a
plane's whereabouts will arrive and will
be indicated on the map display here is
a piece tarpon a Carolina subtitled
Hilla Billy are more upon armor named
for a box turtle to honor troops serving
in Iraq Mel Chin's assemblage which
contains among other things a flattened
shopping cart broken multi paneled
window and a chunk of concrete is in the
exact width and height of a humvee
hillbilly amor takes the term hillbilly
armor which is scavenge materials used
by soldiers for improvised
bulletproofing and vehicle hardening
especially in Iraq we call it hillbilly
armor a soldier says because all we did
was cut out thick steel and put it on
our doors we have a really good welder
who worked really hard on that to give
us extra profession extra protection
while Rumsfeld was saying well you go to
the war with the army you have his good
news about the efforts overseas rarely a
good medium for presenting complexity
television tended to promote the image
of us versus them the yes men this is
really fun here so you got to pay
attention to dates for a moment this is
a piece from the new york times on
saturday july 4th 2009 which was
disseminated in an edition of 80,000
copies on november 12 2008 so the fake
edition of the paper was handed out on
the streets of New York and Los Angeles
by a couple of thousand volunteers the
fake edition shows their ideas for a
better future with headlines such as the
Iraq war ends and nation sets its sights
on building sane economy the French page
contained a spoof model all the news we
hope to print from the famous phrase all
the news that's fit to print articles
the paper announces dozens of new
initiatives including an establishment
of national health care maximum wage for
CEOs and an article where in George W
Bush accuses himself of treason for his
actions during his years as president
there is also a Reuters photo of the
fake cover page and a fake website so
when hearing again pay attention to the
date august 31st 2010 so not so long ago
President Obama declared an end to the
American combat mission in Iraq what
does this mean Aaron Hughes an artist
and organizer for the Iraqi Veterans
Against the War and member of the winter
soldiers asked troops in Iraq have been
drawn down from 90,000 or this year to a
total of forty nine thousand seven
hundred US troops as of august
twenty-third 2010 all other nations by
the way have withdrawn their troops this
does not include the as of marsh 2010
more than 200,000 private contractors
more private contractors than soldiers
were killed in Iraq and Afghanistan in
recent months the first time in history
that corporate casualties have
outweighed military losses on America's
battlefields but then there are four
times as many of them when President
Obama spoke of truth depths deaths in
Afghanistan early this month he made no
mention of fatalities among the private
work force which the State Department is
planning to more than double this is a
project by Jennifer caridee a photo
series entitled soldier stories
from Iraq and Afghanistan which is her
reenacting of their most acute memories
as they transition to civilian life the
title of this piece is an extended one
which is former staff sergeant Starlin
Lara see detachment 38th personnel
services battalion 1st Infantry Division
US Army veteran of Operation Iraqi
Freedom Treasure Island san francisco CA
january 2010 so even without reading the
whole interviews that are also very much
a part of the peace and the photographs
are not meant to stand on their own for
time then i will just tell you the title
of this piece which is captain Elizabeth
a condom New York Army National Guard
veteran of Operation Iraqi Freedom with
daughter Kate and mother Elizabeth Troy
New York jun 2008 ok so in interrupting
a day at the beach at Coney Island you
could see scenes of the United States
government rough government's rougher
practices presented by the artist steven
powers who is being deliberately
provocative what's more obscene he asks
the official position that waterboarding
is not torture or our official position
that it's a thrill ride for jenis carter
who had her 10 year old grandson Roger
in tow she saw the animatronic figures
is just another Coney Island scam it's a
gimmick she said when they have a
sideshow you see real people that's
legit but this here ah so some of these
things you should be chuckling at even
if they're true yeah thank you and I
need a chuckle for well you owe me one
okay so jenny holz her in her series
archive takes her titles also from the
documents that are actually government
files that through their feet or move in
from
asian act she was able to get for
example post-mortem examination DOD 003
146 DOD 003 147 in parentheses green
white a physician examination form for a
war crime victim that uses the documents
code abusive power comes as no surprise
in the beginning of war will be kept
secret are other kinds of phrases that
Holt's are uses to describe her pieces
so that the piece here is extremely
remote and clinical and she shows the
redacted forms of the documents that she
gets by printing them in all of their
imperfections and ugliness later Abdul
is an Afghani video artist and she talks
about in this case she's using the
bombed ruins in cobbles former White
House the presidential palace which he
spent three days painting and
whitewashing with the implications that
are involved in that and she has quotes
from seeing scenes where she remembers
seeing children trying to console their
parents with Joe's they're still playing
painting laughing faces on rocks someone
told me that letters fall from the sky
but it doesn't matter if it doesn't fly
as long as you think you're controlling
it they don't speak like children on my
back they decided to still circle it so
she's talking about the children dealing
with destroyed airplanes and then
filling the bullet holes in with cotton
she was very moved by that and so she
has the children with strings that are
tethering to the airplane and pretending
as though they have some power to like a
kite get it airborne again
okay bunch of stuff about what we're
doing earlier about raising taxes taxes
in Afghanistan and threatening to
withdraw funding for the flood relief if
they don't raise the taxes so that they
can be expending more money on the war
effort here's a piece by sassani Slovak
titled rebuild 2008 it's an interesting
Kate interesting case in multiple
cultures coming together in that it's a
15th century border that was around a
Chinese dignitary portrait that is now
located in Istanbul but was actually
from a 15th century to breetz library
and that leads us to a project by jeremy
deller creative time in the new museum
new york Esther impreza Jonathan Harvey
and NATO Thompson called it is what it
is and for this they took a car that was
bombed and drug it through the United
States on the back of a trailer as they
went across the country to speak to
people about the Iraq war s rom is Iraqi
and so he was serving as a translator
but also an expert on Iraqi culture and
Jonathan Harvey is a returned military
personnel who can be called at any time
back to Iraq and the whole premise of
their project was to engage people in
discussing what their experiences and
what their uncertainties are about Iraq
what is potentially controversial here
is his own statements that this also
took place by the way in Iraq in
Baghdad they had simultaneous
conversations where they would go over
to Iraq and then interview people there
as well as engaging the American public
but Deller says that that he was
expecting to have a lot of opinions
which he did in the project but that the
project isn't about there is about the
war but it's not anti yet it's too late
to be anti it to make an anti peace
there's no point in that this is really
about it and about information about it
so one could take issue with that
perhaps but he does have the caveat that
he thinks it might not be too late to
have projects that would be anti the
Afghani war which is curious since that
is now 10 years old okay so Walid rod
I'm sorry waffle Bilal is in Iraqi and
for this project 10 I'm sorry and
Counting which took place from 8pm March
eighth 2 8pm March 9 2010 he had
multiple thousands of tattoo pricks put
in his back those of the cities in
Baghdad were and were tattooed in red
ink and were visible and then he had one
dot pricking his back in ultraviolet
light that became invisible for every
Iraqi death that had been there which
has been well over a hundred thousand at
the time of the piece that you can see
under black light okay and another case
in point that you would probably
appreciate is that he set up a project
called domestic tension where you could
interact with him in real time online
and shoot a paintball at him
for 31 days and so the objective was to
ways a rare net weight raise awareness
of virtual war and privacy or lack
thereof in the digital age okay close
enough all right now here with Emily I
thought this is particularly interesting
because if we go here she was
demonstrating against the murders that
took place in Israel of the Turkish
peace activists that were killed during
the flotilla and she is an American
Jewish art student studying at Cooper
Union and was over there protesting
after that and was shot by israeli
defense forces in the eye with a tear
gas canister and is now permanently
blind in that eye and i wanted to show
this photograph because we're usually
thinking of the victimized vulnerable
Palestinians but here it's the
palestinian who's protecting the
westerner who goes over and i will
conclude here with a project by anita
manuella i'm sorry inigo mangala no
avala called phantom truck which is a
stupendous piece that is one that was in
the venice biennale in 2007 which is a
full-scale reconstruction of the trucks
that supposedly colin powell found us to
be knowing weapons of mass destruction
were being produced in them so that
pretty much brings us for a full circle
to
where we started with these mythical not
knowns and I'm sorry I'll have to be
more coherent on that in another case
but I did want to just leave on a
positive note which is that you can get
some good iranian food at our own
conflict kitchen and I hope you please
do nice colorful images nice Iranian
people to engage with and I think that
that is one of the common denominators
of the projects that we've seen is a
willingness to actually engage and to
try to disseminate information and to
challenge what it is that we're being
fed all the time Thank You
question-and-answer where you're both
present and
and take exception to each other arm is
a city in places show this ticket on
questions comments questions
a question for a dope um when you
discuss the war on terror I'm going to
age where I've lived through a war on
cancer or war on poverty war on
inflation and so the war on terror is
sort of is a trope it seems that the
government uses but I was curious about
your thoughts about another phrase that
emerged which was the Department of
Homeland Security and whereas oh the war
has been used almost to the point of
having very fractured meetings the
Department of Homeland Security is
fascinating because it almost sounds
like somebody sat down and tried to
figure out what would be the opposite of
a war on terror to and I don't have you
thought about that at all now I haven't
never really considered that that name
department of homeland security but I
mean it is interesting how you know we
used to have a department of war and
then of course that shifted to the
Department of Defense so there is
something to the way we name our
institutions that maybe has somewhat of
a masking effect on on the policies that
that were engaged in so again I haven't
really given much thought to the
department homeland security but it
cinda to look at in more detail
the more you start on that will desire
to go to war and described as a warm
heart because it contradicts very much
the cities in Long Island which is
something quite clear math and there
were artists making work by that
situation in the world called undulator
is a curator and imperial war museum a
moment was secretly collecting work but
the trustees of the museum would not
proficient about that work because
Britain denied that they were more the
United is over i bought a shirt
interesting
is someone trying to chat
died of an erection to admit our fear
through the use of that word and then
another season we got you have a warm
occupation requires a command
yeah that's very interesting and of
course what Korea wasn't a war either it
was a conflict right or a police action
I guess is how we refer to the war there
in that Peninsula but so there is some
you know playing around with the labels
maybe you have something like these is
going to be you know maybe in the kissa
Iraq will be the Bush administration
very much wanted to go in and I think in
northern are
yeah it was very clear within which is
narrative about the war on terror that
rock is just another front of this
overarching single war and so you know
we could arguably look back to early 90s
there was this policy of regime change
in Iraq but after nine eleven that all
sort of got erased and instead of this
policy of regime change in and of itself
as an objective we have the war on
terror acting as an umbrella that allows
them for the discourse of justification
of that enactment of that policy so you
know I think it's interesting and we saw
that in a couple of the slides that we
looked at how there is this discursive
struggle over how to define the war in
Iraq you know Bush is very adamant it's
part and parcel of the war on terror
it's the central front in the war on
terror it's a theater in the war on
terror it's not the war in Iraq but you
know opponents we're trying to redefine
it as a civil war if it's a civil war
then it can't really be part of the war
on terror necessarily it's sort of a
separate conflict so there's this you
know struggle over how to how to define
it which has huge implications for
United States policy
generic term life is going anywhere you
know just
yeah absolutely there's no not
necessarily necessarily and I ten people
in the end 501 yeah well and it is open
in as well as open-ended so it's not
just the war in Afghanistan and the war
in Iraq but there's this open and honest
about the narrative itself that could
potentially open the door to other
invasions Iran perhaps was in the you
know is another one where another front
could have potentially opened up we
didn't see him go there completely but
this open-ended nature of the narrative
i think it is fascinating i do with that
in more detail in my in my book there's
also the language to which is good
reaction to surprise attack over
tradecentre dairy have a surprise attack
and we're back to warn Pearl Harbor and
there was an axis of evil Richard
invention but early on so they were
using real words in terms & fri the side
where the word to you totally avoiding
me going to Vietnam references so we
went right to the good water which then
fit in when they started to quickly find
weapons of mass destruction then they
can use to rid more than bringing
impressive which
to concept which is very well covered in
the popular culture films television
shows
you know which i think the band of
brothers was nothing worth something to
remind us that we were good people find
a good
well in fact that is endemic in
presidential rhetoric in general I'm
working on another project right now
that's looking all the way back to
Woodrow Wilson and how there's this
generic presidential war narrative
better that you know exists that all the
presidents draw from each time to trying
to justify the use of military force and
very much plays on these themes that you
just mentioned so World War two you know
that's a traditional war so it provides
this ideal source domain for
understanding this what happens on 911
and it provides you know almost an ideal
model in many ways for for narrating it
as a war but he also makes use of the
Cold War in the narrative quite a bit
because this bush points out the war on
terror is a new kind of war and so in
many ways it resembles this ideological
struggle that the Cold War was about so
he sort of mixes both of these source
domains together within his narrative
drawing on them as as needed to
construct this idea of the war on terror
but these historical references are very
fascinating I think we see a lot of
presidents always going back to World
War two because that's you know the good
war as you said that's sort of you know
sticks in the National imagination as as
everything that's good about the
American use of military force so
actually going to throat yeah just say
something relative to that which is that
the moral high ground then by going back
to World War two is what we're trying to
establish which is so in congruent with
what the realities are that I think
that's part of the reason why Jeremy
Deller is going across the country
saying that he's not making an anti-war
piece but because we've got eighty five
percent of the population which is
against the war and so just talking
ought to help by introducing them to an
axe
we'll live token Iraqi what's going on
because people who were most embracing
of this war thinking that it is about
freedom and liberation find that oh my
god now I'm forced to talk to this Iraqi
who is someone that they were trying to
liberate right so everything gets turned
on top of itself and the same is true
with the liberation of women in
Afghanistan because the implications are
our policies are making it exactly the
opposite of that women are more
imprisoned in their houses in part for
fear of being blown up by us which is a
very real one so not only is it
reinforcing the atrocities that the
society in its dire patriarchal nature
is instilling on itself but then it's
also got the real world aspects of being
blown up by planes that are flown
remotely and have taken our human agency
away from doing so and our moral
culpability so it's it's increasingly
difficult to be able to maintain the
high line
was so striking with one hand in the
Adams talked we talked about the sort of
I guess the politics of the rhetoric
right so that it's not just about
something that's imposed from top down
but rather than in every instance where
that rhetoric is taken and Reese pokin
or refrain or there's this moment
political possibility and you know it's
the so-called implantation but that
enters what you focused on you focused
very much on the rhetorical possibility
or the politics that were purely in that
moment of rhetorical reverberation and
where's Andrew seem like so many of the
works through the artworks you're
talking about are the ended our are not
I mean they made a rhetorical aspects
but they also go beyond
in a sense it's like separate since the
artist you mentioned that exact quote
political decision is how you drag
people's eyes you could you know
generalize beyond that that's division
but they're they're feeling their their
senses their ability to you know have
some sort of do engage with a material
object you might not be about war on
terror with or without quotes or
capitalized but about something else
that this is enormous possibility and
that's something else that's not
rhetorical so I guess I wanted to push
both you and this question where do we
think about politics in this as
something that's either rhetorical or or
non rhetoric or not necessarily be
engaged with rhetoric but I think the
key question there is how do we achieve
social transformation and maybe you have
some ideas on how art can sort of factor
into that process and I guess part of my
argument that I was trying to make is
that even if there is this will be my
thing as a dominant or dominating
discourses hegemonic discourse that's
out there that sort of constrains the
way that we view the world and how we
talk about the world it doesn't
foreclose the possibility for change I
think if we look closely there's a lot
of play within that system and there's a
lot of potential possibilities for how
that system can be incrementally moved
from within so yeah well I would argue
that every one of the pieces that I was
showing is rhetorical is conscious of
what moves it's making that way and
certainly it's true that they are
advocating and trying to find new ways
to actually bring that change forth and
so there are that's why it's choosing
examples that are both in traditional
art context where you've got pieces that
are being sold for a hundred thousand
dollars right so that you could still
think of painting as a painting and yet
they're bringing these other issues into
that form so that even when you have the
painting behind you on the couch it's
pretty hard to
extricate yourself from what it's
textual meaning is but then with the
Trevor Paglen pieces where we have the
increasingly out of focus things it's a
whole different way about thinking of
photography and the credibility of
photography right it's not just the fact
that digital manipulation has undermined
the veracity of what's going on right
and that ontologically i think is being
a lessening of its force but that those
are constraints that he's actually
taking on to say wait a minute are
touring things by showing you the fact
that you can make a clearer picture of
something that's 500 million miles away
then it is 40 miles away because of the
compressed atmospheric conditions that
we have to start to renegotiate what it
is that we're looking at and what the
and with the titles knowing what the
images is of and yet not being able to
reconcile what we're seeing with that
then throws us back on ourselves and I
wanted to mention that with this from
when he was being taken around with
jeremy deller in that project then yeah
he was asked continually about where the
weapons of mass destruction were and so
even though we think that we're dealing
with a more mediated society it doesn't
really filter down and there are lots of
ways that we have to continue to
interact with each other outside of the
media loop
you didn't talk about any of your
homework in terms of adopting the
rhetoric of anti-war five movements
with the rhetoric that
yeah there's also within these works
there's multiple levels of historical
awareness and referential T where the
art workers coalition from 1971
reproduced a photograph of the My Lai
massacre with dead women and babies all
over the street now we aren't able to
show any photographs of returning
soldiers even though Obama said that
we're able to do so right so very tricky
sort of maneuvers that happen that way
is well because we can say oh well it's
okay as long as the family say that it's
okay to do it but in actuality we
haven't seen any right so the diffusion
against the censorship is gone but on
the other hand the result is still the
same and I think that we find that
happening that's part of the reason why
I was bringing up about the returning
forces right the end of combat troops
but in fact the forty nine thousand
seven hundred troops that are over there
are all trained combat troops and the
new ones that are going on are writing
out their wills and preparing their guns
before they go over so if we get the
advising role from Vietnam then you know
you get a little bit of David deja vu
there
it's interesting how you mentioned the
censorship that's always an issue in
having a population to address that
that's politically aware because it's
ironic that the only photos are some of
the some of the most dramatic photos
that we received from the war are the
ones taken from people that are
torturing prisoners and after we have
taken on camera digital cameras that
were not they did not attend for those
to leak out but they they did and it
caused a huge
a huge reaction and
a horrifying reality that this is
actually occurring this is happening so
I don't know either of you have looked
into how the internet and mass media has
really like how that interacts with the
materials that are being conveyed to the
public well yeah i would say that there
is an israeli getting the photographs
taken of bound palestinians in images
that are hauntingly evocative of Abu
Ghraib but have been on the web for a
couple of years and only now are getting
attention right so there is this
perpetual fight even within the mediated
society especially since we've got such
a plethora of information that is
choking us as to how to select and
choose what does come to the forefront
and in that way that's part of what
Bulow was doing by having this
interactive game where people can be
shooting at him and getting at the 30th
day he had actually extended because the
gun was going off every second in or
more than every second in life time on
the thirtieth day that sounds ominous
well no okay well thank you much
you